[Music]
with thanksgiving less than a month away
airlines are getting ready for the
holiday travel rush one carrier is
testing a new facial recognition
technology to reduce the time it takes
between arriving at the airport and
getting to your seat errol barnett got a
look at how it works he joins us from
atlanta's main airport arrow good
morning
hey there nate good morning look this is
one of the world's busiest airports 43
million people moved through here in
2020 and come the thanksgiving period
the airline expects two and a half
million travelers and many of them will
look like me right they'll have their
headphones in they'll be juggling
devices walking around with their
carry-on and maybe they will have their
luggage as well it's a lot so delta is
upgrading things so that all you need to
be on your way is your beautiful face
we are in delta's new tsa pre-check
express bag drop facility
rajon goswami says his airline's newest
attraction years in the making will
speed up travel
while major u.s carriers like united and
american are piloting biometric id
checks at limited airport locations
delta wants to be first to offer full
curb-to-gate security centered around
facial recognition
members of delta's loyalty program sky
miles who upload passport details and
have tsa pre-check can soon do this as
soon as you take your mask off it takes
the photograph
it's now using that image that it just
had with your passport number it's
pinging the customs database making sure
there's an image match there and now
here we go our bag tag will print
if successful this reduces the need for
agents while streamlining check-in delta
is partnering with the tsa so security
lines like these should be a breeze it
really reduces that element of human
error how quickly would someone be able
to be verified and move through security
about six to ten seconds and the final
leg where you can use your biometrics is
at the gate no id or boarding pass
necessary
welcome aboard eric all right thanks
delta's byron merit the biggest hurdles
are just um you know speed you know
we're trying to move as fast as we can
and the second thing is that customers
are coming back really fast delta is
testing this and i think they will be
eager to see how people react travel
analyst henry hartevelt says flyers are
overwhelmingly willing to
literally face the future our research
among us airline passengers show four
and five would share personal or
biometric data with an airline they
regularly fly to save time
now this will be a gradual rollout
things will move slowly all the delta
gates here at concourse t in atlanta and
concourse a in detroit will have this
technology and look for those of you
fearful about sharing your travel face
delta says it immediately destroys each
image and for those who don't want to
participate in facial recognition you
just don't opt into the option in the
first place nate
hopefully it makes flying easier one
thing i do know errol you travel in
style you look good brother